everyone I wish I was able to welcome  you to a new episode of your daily  equation didn't work out for today I'm  gonna pick up your daily equation  tomorrow that is Tuesday the date I  guess will be April 29th  so do tune in tomorrow usual time I  think I'm going to focus tomorrow on the  Euler Lagrange equations but don't be  completely disappointed right if you  want you can check out world's hustle  program there's a nice one they just  want to call your attention to it is  called beyond Higgs the wild frontier of  particle physics I moderated it and it's  a program whose mathematical underlying  ideas we will discuss in one of these  episodes when I take on the Higgs field  the Higgs particle but for now check out  that program I think you will enjoy it  and until tomorrow when we'll pick up  your day of the equation take care